Okay, for the first one I'm at five, positive five. So, one, two, three, four,
five. I know that I'm five units away from zero, so I get five. Negative eight
is right here. I know it's eight units away from zero. So this answer is
positive eight. Remember the distance or the absolute value is always positive.
Here's negative five. And just like the first one, that's also five units from
zero, so again five. For 5 plus 2, I'm going to move five units to the right. So
I'd be right here at five, and then I'm going to go two more to the right.
because I have 5 plus 2. So I end up at seven. Whenever you have expressions
inside absolute value you want to simplify them first. Just like parenthesis and
brackets. I would have 5 plus 2 which is 7. The absolute value of 7 is 7. For 2
minus 5 I'm going to start by going positive 2. Notice that when the sign isn't
present it's always positive. So positive two. Then I have to move five units to
the left. One, two, three, four, five. I end up at negative three. I know 2
minus 5 is negative 3. So I have the absolute value of negative three. I'm
trying to find the distance of negative 3 from 0. And I know that's just three
units. All right, nice job on that quiz.